come on no i'm not gonna go i'm gonna
taser you i'm gonna tease you right here
right now
[Music]
it is not oh yes it is it is not your
right yes it is
do you want to sit in my car no i don't
want to sit in your car and i'm not
saying anything
then show me your receipt i will not
show me your receipt
if you took it without paying for it oh
i won't do that then show me your
receipt i won't do that
why i won't do that because do you
realize you can go to jail for that oh i
really if i stole it but i don't stink
you're not cooperating i'm not
cooperating because you ain't got no
probable cause cause they said something
go watch the camera first ma'am i'll
walk back in there with you and go watch
the camera no i'm upset because i don't
have everything i don't have access to
the camera so how they gonna say i stole
if they didn't see me still ma'am what
is your name
what's your name calm down what's your
name no that that i see him every day
listen to me every day
absolutely do you think i want any
trouble do you know how many people
don't walk in that stuff while
ma'am
they simply asked if you had a receipt
they didn't see you go through a
register why won't they go through all
the registers and ask the people if they
see me
ma'am let's come on let's walk back in
where's your receipt come on let's walk
back let's walk back in there bring your
receipt let's walk back
back let's walk back in there just show
me your name no no because that's no i'm
not going to i'm not letting you go back
in the store
is that your receipt from today
but i'm not showing because i ain't got
no reason y'all don't make me show
nothing i can no you actually i can and
you're not giving me your id
so i can't prove that you didn't take
anything no no i don't know anyways why
are we arguing about this because y'all
profile black people every day like
everybody that shops in here is black
everybody's shopping here is black
no everybody ain't well most of them are
they
can profile anybody see i see y'all up
here every day bob
i don't bother anybody whoever can you
just show me your receipt no i'm not
going to do that
because that makes absolutely no sense
at all i'm not going can i see your
receipt
no because they say if they call if they
sent you out here that that means they
saw me still
they didn't see you go through a
registration why
okay step out of the car
i'm not stepping on no call okay you got
kid you all these kids in here you left
in here by yourself do you want me to
push this further well you went in the
store they're not little kids they are
little kids and you left them all in the
store and what are you gonna do when you
go to jail and they're all here so i
called dcf to come get them all my mama
stay right around the corner okay so i
don't have to call your mom to come get
them i can call dcf
they my sister kids they'll call her to
come get her children
why don't you show me your receipt
publix and everybody in there okay step
out of the car i'm not stepping out you
have to step out of the car you have to
call your sergeant or your lieutenant
come on no you're going you're going to
go to jail no i'm not you're going to go
to jail yes you are no i'm not give me
your receipt i'll not give you my
receipt come on no i'm not no i'm not
you're going to jail you're going to
jail no i'm not you are going to jail no
i'm not i'll tell you what i'll do no
i'm not you're going to jail no i'm not
call your mama
come on no i'm not you're going to go
i'm going to taser you i'm going to
tease you right here right now i'm gonna
tease you right now
get out of the car
get out of the car
get out of the car you're under arrest
you're under arrest i'm gonna rest away
get out of the car come on don't run for
what turn around call your mom turn
around right now
get down on the ground
get down on the ground right now
get down put your hand behind your back
right now
right now give me your other hand
right now
lay on your face
[Applause]
oh wow that's really nice thank you
thank you ma'am give me the other hand
give me the other hand right now
i didn't steal nothing
it helped
it's fine
my dad worked on the police department
oh that's really nice
i got it go away
go away keep recording
it
oh yeah
all right keep recording thank you
calm my numbers
[Laughter]
stand up
now you're going to jail
just stay there okay i'll be with you in
a second you think i'm gonna go and
steal some stuff
oh cause i'm black almost zapping it
can you go my fam walk
to the car stop doing that to me walk to
the car
cooperate
i am cooperating walk to the car
can you follow my family for me walk to
the car
it is thank you ma'am
please put it on facebook
hey can you get enough for me
y'all so stupid i'm kidding i'm double
ac
i guess that's what you wanted
that's all you wanted i guess so so i
guess you gave me yeah yeah
what's up
yeah
oh yeah hold on a second i didn't steal
are you talking
are you serious
that's what's wrong with you all night
you tightening my hand and i'm not even
moving my jacket out you doing the most
here yeah you can set her in here
just have a seat
no i just uh
hang on a second
battery my portable is dead
uh
i gotta
i'm good now i had to taser her
can you go back over there for me and
check on that car where she was in which
car was it's the uh
it was a white suv over there there's a
bunch of kids in it okay
thanks
i'm recording right now she uh anna told
me that she walked by i saw her walk by
the back i didn't see her at register
so i go over there to her car just to
check and say hey you got a receipt and
you see a receipt she refuses to show me
your receipt refuse to show me your id
so i'm like listen i mean you know if
you took something here you didn't pay
for it i'll probably trespass you but i
need to see your receipt she wouldn't
show it to me
and uh so
so just got ugly over there so i had to
taser her and stuff she's gonna go to
jail i don't know if she paid for her
stuff or not but
hey
yeah i could work on that in a second
are you going to be over there yeah
okay
yeah for sure
okay i'll come over there in just a
second okay
but uh she's gonna go to jail so
unfortunately i got myself in a big mess
here for no reason all she's gonna do is
show me a receipt she wouldn't do it she
wouldn't give me her id so here i am
it's a mess
who's that other guy uh he works for us
he's off dude he's got his badge with
him so i just had him check on those
kids
i'm sorry mike i got a man
i got some in here i need uh
i need anna's uh date of birth and stuff
okay her information okay
thanks
hs7936
7936
can you send me a supervisor another
unit to publix
at 76 28 103rd street reference to a
15 that i had a taser
and also send me a rescue
you didn't have to pay me you want to
take me you want to keep me in my hand
that you need but it's okay because i'm
thanking god anything
yeah you should have cooperated
you should have cooperated
you have to cooperate what's your first
name i have to give my id i don't yes
you do
no i don't okay
well that's that's that's why you're in
the position you're in
i'm gonna be out
and that's why you're in the position
that you're in nwcb oh well that's
that's the whole reason why you did what
you did then
that's fine with me too
he is fine wonderful
[Music]
you seen me come through
let me step out
hey um
is there any chance we could check the
uh
hold on a second
[Applause]